onyia y noticia con una latinoamericana
en la fórmula 2 de que se trata de
andrés la colombiana tatiana calderón
regresa a la fórmula 2 la gran antesala
de la fórmula 1 la cafetera a terminar
la temporada corriendo las últimas
cuatro citas con la escudería de charles
racing system en reemplazo del turco se
involucraba si la tiene a llegada de
competir en la indycar y vuelve a esta
categoría podemos decir con mucho flow y
es que la reguetonera colombiana carol y
es la nueva patrocinadora de tatiana su
monoplaza cuenta con la inscripción de
tan hombre con el que se ha hecho
a conocer la autora de éxitos como
provença hola tussam la tiene hacer
ahora la compañera de esto fittipaldi
debutó hoy en la clasificación del gran
premio de bélgica terminando en la
última posición que opina tatiana de
esta alianza con carlos jean escuchemos
el mensaje empoderamiento de mujer
colombiana ayuda a la mujer colombiana y
de ojalá mostrar que en el deporte en
muchos ámbitos pues luchar por esa por
esa igualdad de oportunidades sobre todo
pues ella viniendo siendo como la que ha
roto varias barreras en el género urbano
en la música con el reggaetón pues lo
mismo hacer aquí también en el
automovilismo que ha sido pues dominado
por por hombres en ese sentido andrés y
dijo la propia está tiene al calderón
que ahora ya pilota el verdadero
mckinnon